I've got a voicemail for you today that I
suspect I will have viewers and listeners
who will not like this voicemail.
And it is a caller speaking some difficult
truths to a sliver or a slice of the left.
Let's take a listen to it.
Progressive media is really risking jumping
the shark right now.
They're covering stories like the George Bush
story.
And they seem to not understand that people
who do wrong things in the past can occasionally
still be correct in statements they make.
And they're also covering the story with Joe
Biden saying that we told you so Bernie Sanders
would be the president.
No, he wouldn't.
Bernie Sanders couldn't even win the Democratic
nomination.
And it wasn't the DNC fault this time.
The people did not like Bernie Sanders.
They liked Joe by.
Yeah.
OK.
So let's let's deal with that second issue
first.
I've already discussed the Bernie Biden thing,
you know, to to assume that Bernie obviously
would defeat Trump in November.
But Biden won't ignores essentially all of
the facts that we have, including that Bernie
lost the Democratic primary by millions of
votes and that that number may climb as more
primaries are done via mail in ballot.
I don't think we need to address that again.
On the issue of the Bush story, what the caller
is referring to is that over the weekend,
George W. Bush put out a three minute video
where he says the Corona virus is serious.
It's not the time for partisanship.
We need to come together, et cetera.
It's a completely reasonable and accurate
message.
It doesn't mean Bush was right to go into
Iraq.
It doesn't mean Bush was right with the torture.
It doesn't mean anything about Bush other
than he was right about that.
And he's more sensible than Trump on this
issue.
And I covered this yesterday, and I had already
been getting attacked on Twitter for it over
the weekend.
And I got attacked again for rehabilitating
the reputation of a war criminal.
ET cetera, et cetera.
And what I've realized, if I've had it's sort
of an epiphany over the last 10 days.
And I'm going to tell you what it is right
now.
We've got a couple of minutes here before
we wrap the show.
So I'll tell you what it is.
I always tended to just do the show the way
I want to do it and do the stories I want
to do and so on and so forth.
But every once in a while, a little bit of
calculation would enter in where I might say
I need to moderate my language here or there
or whatever, because I risk getting a certain
reaction from my audience, which I would seek
to to avoid.
I'm not really paying any more attention to
that because no matter what I do, that backlash
is going to exist.
In case in point, yesterday I literally said
during my segment about hate, George W. Bush
was right about this one thing.
Right?
This should not be a partisan thing, the corona
virus.
We've got to come together.
Trump is wrong on it.
I said twice in the segment.
Bush is a war criminal.
I called the statement a completely unremarkable,
milquetoast statement.
And yet it still shows us how whacked Donald
Trump is on this and every other issue that
he can't even put out a normal statement one
time, which George W. Bush was able to do,
didn't matter, didn't call him a war criminal
twice in the segment.
And people are saying, David, you are ignoring
the fact that this guy's a war criminal and
real rehabilitating his image.
I called him a war criminal twice during this
segment.
So what I've clearly realized is when people
say, David, you should cover this or you shouldn't
cover that or here's the position, you have
to.
It actually doesn't matter at all if people
have determined that I'm the enemy, if they
want to be mad at me, they're going to be
regardless of what I say.
If I cover a story, if I don't cover it or
whatever.
So if you see any change in the show over
the next couple of weeks, other than the fact
that we've extended the show an additional
10 percent every day, the show is longer now,
which is beautiful.
It's a fantastic thing.
You will see that.
I will be paying even I was paying eight percent
attention before.
Call it to what I expected the reactions to
be to how I take on issues that's going down
to zero.
Some people will like it.
Some people will not.
But alas, such as life.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Become a member at Join Packman dot com.
Do not miss today's bonus show.
It will be a